now as British lawmakers discuss the
next steps in their efforts to leave the
European Union the EU Parliament has
also been discussing brexit EU officials
briefed at lawmakers on last week's
summit when Member States offered
Britain two new options for an orderly
exit comparing the UK to the famously
mysterious Egyptian sphinx EU
commissioner President jean-claude
Juncker said it remains unclear what
London will do but EU Council President
Donald Tusk has urged lawmakers to give
Britain time to rethink its position
you cannot betray the six million people
who sign the petition to revoke article
50 their 1 million people to march for a
people vote or the increasing majority
of people who want to remain in the
European Union they may feel that they
are not sufficiently represented by
their UK Parliament but they must feel
that they are represented by you in this
chamber because they are Europeans thank
you straight to Strasbourg then where we
turn our DW scale gap matters welcome
and Gail and strong words there from
Donald Tusk absolutely a look Donald
Tusk is known to be an emotional speaker
he makes no secret of the fact that he
thinks the UK should stay should change
its mind and seeing that key brexit ears
are now falling in line behind theresa
mais plan behind her deal shows that
there is a fear among brexit ears that
there may be after all no brexit at all
that the remain site suddenly gets a
momentum and for that momentum a tunnel
just would like to see more time so a
long extension and do you think that EU
law makers are likely to heed his words
I think frankly there is no as the sole
secret that there is a brexit fatique
and it's pretty much has reached its
peak and so yes it would be unconvenient
if the UK suddenly participates after
all in the European elections the French
president has said he's not in much in
favour of a long extension but after all
the youth he use
last week has made that suggestion that
that offer is on the table and I think
so what Donald Tusk II refers to is some
Emmy P's on the remain side on the
pro-european side who have said look if
the UK would fall out if it would be a
hard bracket that would be a showcase
that leaving the European Union is just
a bad idea and what else have you
lawmakers been saying about breakfast
today well there is the chief practice
negotiator of the European Parliament
for instance who has said he's a little
less optimistic that Donald Tusk and he
believes that remain has no chance but
then after a couple of years the UK were
returned to the family of EU nations so
there are some some positive words here
from a number of MEP s and finally there
was set dance from the Labour Party in
MEP who said thank you Donald Tusk your
message is well received and we're
grateful for it all right
go matter sir in Strasbourg thank you